[Música]
en revista de prensa hoy hablaremos de
la supuesta adopción por parte de rusos
y el robo de niños a manos de los
militares de niños ucranianos para eso
nos ha comprado nos acompaña Rosa Pérez
más deu Rosa Buenos días bienvenida
Buenos días María Clara bueno y
empecemos con esta noticia porque el
Moscú Times afirma que la representante
de Putin para la infancia está diciendo
que adoptó un menor de edad ucraniano en
la ciudad de maniopolis efectivamente
hablamos de María alfabelova quien tiene
el cargo concretamente de comisionada
rusa de la protección de los derechos de
la infancia y ayer jueves informó al
presidente ruso Vladimir Putin que ha
adoptado un adolescente de 15 años
proveniente de la ciudad de Mario por
recordemos esta ciudad ucraniana bajo
control ruso desde prácticamente el
principio de la guerra prácticamente
bueno particularmente el boba belova
declaró ahora sé lo que significa ser
madre de un niño del donbas es difícil
pero sin duda nos amamos uno al otro y
creo que podemos superar cualquier cosa
bien este caso que puede parecer
particular en realidad habla de una
cuestión que está sucediendo a gran
escala no y es que de hecho el aveloba
esta mujer Es la encargada del programa
que en palabras del propio periódico
moscútime supervisa la deportación
forzada de menores de zonas del este de
Ucrania ocupadas por Rusia hacia campos
de reeducación en Rusia concretamente
según un reporte publicado Este martes
por el hielo humanitario en research lab
de Estados Unidos se estima que habría
unos 6.000 menores ucranianos viviendo
en estos momentos en estos campos de
reeducación en Rusia y de hecho esto
rosa si se llega a comprobar sería
también un crimen de guerra no solo de
una adopción legal efectivamente no sin
duda Y esto es lo que está denunciando
las autoridades ucranianas desde hace
meses de hecho y nos vamos ahora a las
noticias de Estados Unidos porque el New
York Times está preguntándose si lo que
está ocurriendo en Ohio con los químicos
que se liberaron luego del
descarrilamiento de un tren Se trata de
un chernóbil Dos punto cero exactamente
y hace un poco de parodia este artículo
digamos Este título de este artículo más
bien sobre lo que el New York Time
señala que están publicando personas de
todo el espectro político no y es que
publican afirmaciones que tal y como
señala el periodista Que firma este
texto van más allá de los hechos
probados por la ciencia no entre otras
calificaciones esta cuestión del
descarrilamiento del tren en Ohio y el
consiguiente vertido de residuos tóxicos
tóxicos ha sido calificado como la peor
catástrofe Ambiental de la historia o
como chernóbil como bien decías de hecho
existe y es popular el hashtag chernóbil
Ohio como también ha sido calificado de
una plan de la Casa Blanca no de la
Administración biden o también hay
distintos usuarios que rechazan los
reportes científicos de la Epa no de la
agencia de protección ambiental
estadounidense que como nos decía mame
no en los informativos está señalando
que ahora por ahora los niveles de
contaminación tanto del agua como del
aire no tienen un alto nivel de
toxicidad sin embargo que hay que
esperar a los informes que se vayan
realizando a largo plazo bueno Y esta
desinformación es una de las cosas que
está lamentando un medio local en Ohio
exactamente hablamos del Pittsburgh
podcast
que citan a Chris ready que es un
químico estadounidense de Massachusetts
que dice no pongo en duda que estos
químicos tengan un alto nivel de
complejidad Pero esto no es chernóbil
Ninguno de los químicos liberados es
radiactivo también citan a la doctora
maorín liechbell quien es especialista
en salud pública y quien ha trabajado en
emergencias como el 11 de septiembre o
el Catrina y que señala que el estrés
psicológico puede provocar los mismos
síntomas que los que se atribuyen
químicos como las náuseas o los dolores
de cabeza que están denunciando muchos
de los residentes de ispa al Style de
hecho esta doctora especialidad
especializada en salud pública dice la
gente de la zona está muy preocupada
angustiada y Cuanto más tardemos en
responder a esta angustia mayor será la
ansiedad y el estrés bueno Pero además
esta no es la primera vez que se
descarrila un tren y que tenía químicos
tóxicos no es así exactamente Y esto es
precisamente lo que señala lynsley una
periodista de investigación del medio
local también de Ohio Dayton Daily que
recupera una investigación Que ella
misma hizo en 2014 cuando Ohio ya
ocupaba el tercer lugar en el lamentable
ranking de los lugares donde ocurren los
accidentes de trends más peligrosos con
mercancías tóxicas no y lo que señala es
que en ese momento cuando llevó a cabo
esa investigación las causas que
provocaban estos accidentes son las
mismas que tienen lugar hoy en día no y
precisamente Cuáles son estas causas
bien pues tal y como señala periodista
está lógica de la industria ferroviaria
de reducción de costos que lleva una
reducción de personal más estrés en los
trabajadores que conducen trenes más
pesados y más largos recordemos que en
2021 la compañía que cuyo tren de
escarriló propuso un plan que quería a
lo largo de tres años ampliar en un 20%
la magnitud a la longitud y la carga de
los trenes de momento no hay límites no
a la longitud de los trenes pero también
hay un problema de falta de alerta
temprana y es que para terminar María
Clara este tren que descarriló en
spanish pasó una hora antes por la
localidad de Salem donde tenía lugar
donde estaba instalado un detector de
temperatura del calor que no hizo saltar
la alarma no que supondría que Tendría
que haber saltado dado que en ese
momento según cámaras de seguridad el
tren ya estaba en llamas lo que podría
indicar entonces que era una tragedia
que se podía evitar Rusia Gracias por
estar con nosotros Nos vemos mañana